but first
hijacking democracy that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now today if you weren't up super early
you might have missed something super
pretentious and super hypocritical biden
hosted something called the summit for
democracy
choices we make in my view in the next
in this moment are going to
fundamentally determine the direction
our world is going to take in the coming
will
decades
allow the backward slide of rights and
democracy to continue uncheck
or will we together together
have a vision
and the vision not just a vision no
vision and courage
to once more lead the march of human
progress and human freedom forward
of course the ultimate irony here is
that almost everything the democrats are
doing in supporting these days weakens
our democracy and our freedom
mandating vaccines and masks
investigating concerned parents calling
them terror threats of course canceling
political adversaries via their social
media pals appeasing china eliminating
voter id opposing signature verification
in elections and promoting ballot
harvesting does any of that sound pro
freedom to you
thus when biden warns about democracy
backsliding
he's preemptively excusing what will
likely be a crushing loss for his party
in the midterms and even in 2024.
you know they're desperate when they
send out the person with the approval
rating of i don't know a planter's wart
here in the united states we know that
our democracy is not immune from threats
january 6
looms large in our collective conscience
and the anti-voter laws that many states
have passed are part of an intentional
effort
to exclude americans from participating
in our democracy
yeah
her argument is actually that law is
requiring you to show an id to vote or
to clear dead people off the voting
rolls to verify signatures on mail-in
ballots
they're somehow to her anti-democratic
because they believe illegal immigrants
should vote and they think the biggest
threats facing america look like this
guy
the coors light trespasser who took
selfies in the capitol on january 6th
you see that guy
yeah kamala
that guy and others like him they're
gonna throw us into a totalitarian abyss
so pathetic
now the reason democrats are so rabid
about the so-called freedom to vote act
that got invoked a lot today is that in
practical terms it would be a democrat
incumbent protection racket
among other things it would bypass state
authority by nationalizing rules for
voter registration and mail-in ballots
that means buh-bye meaningful election
security laws
of course liberals though get lots of
help from media elites to sell their
myths about the dark cloud
anti-democracy cloud hanging over the
gop
people like former conservatives david
brooks who are kind of stuck in an early
2000s time warp
helped market the trump as authoritarian
myth writing
trumpian authoritarianism doesn't
renounce holy war it embraces holy war
assumes it is permanent in fact c seeks
to make it so
in the trumpian world disputes are
settled by raw power and intimidation
holy war
has david never heard of dick cheney
does he really not know how often the
bush family relied on raw power and
intimidation to get its way
but brooks goes on
as long as the warrior ethos dominates
the gop brutality be it will be admired
over benevolence propaganda over
discourse confrontation over
conservatism dehumanization
over dignity
two words david
abu grabe
now who was president when that was
going on
and who was the vice president
no
hint it wasn't donald trump or mike
pence
the establishment that we've known for
decades is steadily losing power and
being replaced by smarter better people
i like to think of
mike pompeo as secretary of state versus
anthony blinken
enough said now not only is the gop
getting smarter its reach is broadening
and now appealing to minorities once
thought safely in the democrat camp at
least they were
under previous years in 2020 trump put
together the most diverse gop coalition
in 60 years how's that authoritarian
hispanic voters in texas florida are
flocking to the republican banner
republicans also made huge inroads with
suburban women in virginia who were
concerned about what their kids are
being taught in school and then vilified
for it
now the fact is republicans not
democrats have become more democratic
think about it this way since 1988
the gop was essentially run by one
family the bushes
now if you're on their good side all was
well but if you question them oh my
goodness if you dared to criticize them
you were shunned
but it's not a democracy when your party
is controlled by big donors and one
small clique or family
for years the conservative grassroots
they were demanding real change in
things like foreign policy border policy
trade policy
but they were summarily ignored
until trump came along
now david brooks and others like him
they want to return to the old days when
the gop voters lost gracefully and
lost regularly by following naive
globalist dreamers
we see a china that is becoming one of
the most dynamic
and creative societies in the world
america welcomes the emergence
of a strong
and peaceful
and prosperous china
which brings me back to biden's summit
today
now the biggest tell that this has
nothing to do with promoting democracy
is the fact that the president of the eu
was invited
we know how painful it is
when a small group takes unlimited power
and imposes a single vision
on all of society it is why we have put
forward measures
to help protect people
online from illegal content
hidden political advertisement
or disinformation
it is why we are proposing to add hate
speech and hate crime
to the list of crimes in our treaties
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna trust her to
regulate hate speech okay
now let's see a transnational
undemocratic body that's totally
unaccountable to the voters in their own
countries
imposing
speech restrictions to punish their
political opponents now of course biden
and pelosi would love nothing more than
to do the same here and they're trying
to
they see what's coming down the road if
they actually let democracy play out
here
so they're going to pull out all the
stops to make sure that does not happen
even if they have to hijack democracy
to do it and that's the angle